dans la grande famille de la canne vous
connaissez déjà le sucre mais il y a
aussi Mister bagasse avec lui le courant
passe très bien il utilise la bagasse de
la canne broyée pour fournir un dixième
de l'électricité de la Réunion comme la
bagasse et la deuxième source d'énergie
renouvelable après l'eau Mr bagasse peut
renvoyer 138000 tonnes de charbon chez
eux
là vous avez Marie engrais oui la canne
est aussi écolo Marie engrais récupère
les écumes qui proviennent de
l'épuration du jus de canne pour en
faire de l'engrais et ça marche elle
sait aussi que 85000 tonnes d'écume
valorisés évite d'utiliser 2500 tonnes
d'engrais chimiques et maintenant place
à Mademoiselle mélasse aussi
utile dans les élevages
que dans les distilleries
monsieur Courtepaille lui permet aussi à
la canne de produire de la litière du
fourrage pour animaux et du compost pour
culture maraîchère et plantes à parfums
et enfin voici Cannes force verte
défenseur de l'environnement il lutte
contre l'érosion des sols
il absorbe l'équivalent du CO2 émis par
le parc automobile de la Réunion il fait
régner l'harmonie dans les villes oui la
canne s'étouffait mais là aussi des
ennemis parmi eux le vert blanc